the difference between reality and on  the show as Cheryl David I'm not as  entertained by what's going on there was  an episode where we were renewing our  vows I thought we were gonna stay  together during the afterlife I didn't  know we wanted to return it together it  carries over so I think in real life I  would be like you're an idiot but Cheryl  David was not realm there's a lot of  Leon and JB Beth there's no GP in the  Leon doughnut compose himself we have a  cross his [ __ ] right leg over the  left leg  Leon he dresses shabby first of all we  don't dress alike at all  Wow good afternoon General Petraeus John  Varvatos really tired collapsed right  blood I wish that I was as comfortable  in my anger as she is and I wish that I  was able to just walk around telling  everybody to go [ __ ] themselves [ __ ] out  of here all right okay  [Music]